annie what's going on with with your
body you're you're strolling in here
you're telling us that you're you're big
don't no wait don't take such joy you're
telling us that you haven't she
shows food in her fat mouth tell me the
story while i look at you
[Laughter]
okay because of my cluster headaches
well right before my clustering i hurt
my shoulder
using whitney's row machine whitney
cummings
i have very rich friends um
i wanted this row machine really bad i
saw it at uh
best buy and i was like oh i want this
road machine it's like the
peloton of row machines well you were at
best buy
this was like three months ago why
something for todd's hopefully a britney
spears cd
i go to best buy for my cds when it's
2005.
what do you do really best buy not
tower because remember in tower records
you could listen to all you could
preview all of the
all of the entire cd before you buy it
that or you go down to penny lane
and you get that cd like i used to get
um the the chronic two
i got it for like two bucks and it was a
brand new season i used to go in uh
in philly i used to go to south street
to use
cd stores that was fun that sounds fun
green day
um do you have that time to swallow your
food before you talk in the podcast
just i don't it's like it and it's what
is it that you were eating this is a
slim crunchy peanut butter vegan bar i
don't normally eat these but i was in a
rush today i don't like
oh cause you don't want to like promote
it no i i just i don't like eating
protein bars
that's like is the first word on that
i've seen this [ __ ]
listen i've seen this [ __ ] eating bars
i don't know what's going on not
and not in covet times because in cover
times you can eat all your meals like
slowly at home
because you're not on the go go go i've
never seen her done anything slowly
i don't know what narrative you're
trying to spin here
i've said this before in pockets esther
punches food into her face
she smacks it it's like the biggest
handful like those little hands
it's a real size handful it's like it's
all bubbling out of the hand
yeah she double-hands it you know when i
go to the movie theaters i have a strict
policy
i'm not cheering popcorn do you
understand get it through your heads now
friends
is it so you can play with your own
penis
[Music]
no i just i don't want your hands in my
popcorn covered or not covered
vaccine or not vaccine i just want to
show you nobody wants your creepy little
hands and theirs
your nasty little tiny hands
you know what's scary how much how often
your hand would be in the popcorn i
wouldn't know
that's scary to me i want to be aware of
your hands at all times
and in fact if i do go to the movie
you're pretending that people are
fighting to share a problem with you you
listen
up you listen up if i do go to the news
with you and i have to go to the
bathroom i'm taking a picture of my
popcorn before i go so that it looks
exactly the same when i'm
i'm surprised you wouldn't take your
popcorn with you oh i don't want to talk
about it when you go to the bathroom i'm
taking your popcorn with me to the
bathroom
and i'm taking a very different picture
of it i i'm
buttering it up i'm adding a little
spice to it i think annie's 20 21 goal
is to hold hands
in your popcorn with you you guys i saw
honestly i saw the uh this is the most
one of the most
monumental moments of my life my dad
used to pick me i've told this story
before so maybe you've heard it but
my dad used to pick me up from high
school and we would go to this movie
theater and watch all the critically
acclaimed movies but we wouldn't know
anything about them ahead of time we
would just know that they were the good
ones
so my dad would pick me up and the best
part about it was that there was no one
in the theater so it was just
like this moment where we're watching
this movie by ourselves we can talk to
whatever
he picks me up one day from school and
he goes all right we're going to go see
this movie called rec room for a dream
and we went and we saw it together
record for dream we got like a large
thing of popcorn do you know what
happens in this movie no there's a
there's an ass-to-ass scene you might be
very interested in it it's like there's
how does that work okay so it's one end
of the dildo and one girl's butt the
other get entered a dildo in
another girl's butt and they go they
they gyrate backwards into the dildo
it's
just both asses are having a banana
break at the same time
towards each other please play the
banana break song and
jennifer connolly doing ass to us what
jennifer connelly from house of santa
and pho
you know what's official she looks like
her she thinks she looks like her i can
always tell when esther
she looks i just love her performance in
in some movies
i poked into an esther club once and
esther was talking about
oh yeah rachel cook she's like and she
was the most
gorgeous girl there ever was and i'm
like esther looks like
esther has the same face shape like you
can tell like no that
the movie she's all that they paint her
out to be this ugly little
hog and she's gorgeous why are you so
triggered by this
because you feel like this is your life
because it's ruined my childhood this
room in my life
i think i'm an ugly [ __ ] piece of dog
[ __ ]
because i have brown hair and i'm short
she's not even she didn't even look like
you mousey
you're wearing pretty much the same
outfit she wore when she was the loser
you are blonde and blue eyes so you've
been green eyes
you've been portrayed in media your
whole life as a [ __ ] hot child
and you are you are not like me oh yeah
i'm like you yeah oh my god she's a
model that's so embarrassing she's
obviously like a full-blown model
no but she wasn't portrayed in media as
beautiful you were a model hand model
my hands they cropped everything out of
your body except for it were you really
a hand modeler yeah for american girl
doll catalog and a pillsbury commercial
i'd let you be like a model of this part
of your face
that's a hot spot i wanted to be an
actress but things turned into just hand
modeling
annie so what happened in the movies um
okay so we're going to
tell my dad but i was just thinking
about how we we were looking straight
forward like
esther the assassin might have been the
the most family friend
friendly party yeah i'm telling you it
might have been the nicest scene
no truly she's not excited it's one of
the worst it was it's like having a
nightmare
and a fever at the same time while
watching yeah it's like ellen
bursting's um scenes where she um she's
an older lady who becomes very crazed
about this one tv
show she thinks she's going to be a part
of so every day she's watching it's like
a fever dream
it repeats repeats repeats she gets more
crazed as each day goes and then there's
another scene where
a [ __ ] heroine stick turns becomes
infected
and that just [ __ ] me it's just so
like there's a scene where like this
woman's so [ __ ] up that like
like the refrigerator starts shaking at
her like it's just so scary
question how would you rank it watching
requiem with a dream with your dad
working for a dream we call it with a
dream when my dad's there
how would you rank that against watching
pulp fiction with your dad wait
right now nothing pulp fiction is like
are you watching bambi yeah
she's right it's bambi compared to
requiem and both not even bambi because
bambi
is like traumatic as the mom dies which
by the way still hurts oh that hurts me
i also have a true question about that
like did they think that we could
emotionally as kids handle that scene
it's because it was devastating for me i
dreamt about it i cried about it
you're always a lion king and uh even in
frozen the parents die but they die like
on a [ __ ] like you don't really like see
it but these ones like we know the mom's
about to like
they they just put suspenseful music can
we not we have to do no no did you guys
see a.i
when you were little i did i wasn't that
old
probably so was i yeah have you ever
seen me when you weren't little oh wait
not possible
but ai [ __ ] me up when he's like
searching for his mom the little robot
boy
like didn't that mess you guys up oh my
god that was that was sad but i think i
was old enough to
um kind of um reconcile with my feelings
at that time what [ __ ] me up as a
child
like stupid [ __ ] i had like demonic
dreams about it was [ __ ]
charlie in the chocolate factory i think
that's not
uh child appropriate at all it's scary
because it's like do all those kids go
die
when they all get like sick and stuff
and yeah i was like where
what is happening can i guess who esther
related to the most in the
daddy
[Laughter]
oh my god it's so good i would love to
see you shooting through like a little
tube of chocolate
it's so true that the second i got to
the chocolate factory it'd just be like
sia and i'd like jump into the chocolate
what are other really traumatic oh very
very impressionable two movies that
really made an impact on me when i was
younger during library or
hour when we would have to watch movies
was twister
oh i can't believe you just brought that
up i can't the best right
three movies scariest because i have a
quick twister story my dad took me to
see twister and within the first two
minutes of the movie a little yorkie dog
is outside and i said dad we're leaving
and we i left the theater and didn't
finish it
that [ __ ] little that upset you you
should see chernobyl because there's a
scene with puppies though oh my goodness
so dedicated to puppies
i saw i that was not necessary to be in
that show
it was honestly the only thing that
mattered i feel like it could have been
a very short show
that was the most impactful where i was
like oh i thought this is bad what
happened
i thought you did not need that that
episode it was a whole episode dedicated
to
shooting dogs that's the worst thing
i've ever seen in my life yeah same
it's like the rule also in tv is like
don't hurt animals because it makes
it like makes everybody watching
uncomfortable well let me tell you what
movie not to watch ever in your life is
amores perros
it's a spanish movie by um inarito and i
made bobby watch it
two weeks ago and he hates me to this
day he's like i don't
understand so long ago that's what the
two boys right that were in e2 mama
tambien or just
yeah those little guys were so cute they
would make esther look tall they would
but going back to twister so yeah the
movie theater you never watched the
whole thing no i was like dad dad
we have to leave i was so scared by the
little dog in a tornado
whenever twister came out what if it's
like i found out what your twister was
what if i was probably like
10. or i was probably 9. and you know
what's so interesting about twisters so
i looked up the impact because that
means that was such a big impact
it was so much good about it because i
don't know what happened just as a kid i
don't know there's sort of blockbusters
as a kid
we probably saw it over christmas like
all those movies deep impact armageddon
twister apollo 13. oh yeah oh my god
i i the greatest movie of all time to
this day
what movie what year was it george 1996.
i was like oh i was
oh i was 12 11 11. i was eight
that was a swing for your dad to take
you there well oh that's my whole i
remember
when land before time came out at the
same time as jurassic park and i got to
school on monday
and all my kids all the kids were like
there before time i was like oh my
family took me to see jurassic park and
i'm scared like
they never i never got to go to kid
stuff they were just like they didn't
want to pay a babysitter so i just went
and did all adult stuff
let me tell you that's why i'm so cool
and that's why you're repressed as a
child forever
let me tell you it's a good thing you
don't watch land before time because
another thing like emotionally like who
could handle at that age the death
of a [ __ ] cute dinosaur i know you
know what i mean
why do they have to teach us like this
like
our parents don't have to well
eventually they always do
teach us the ultimate lesson the one
thing that i remember about land before
by killing us
by i esther and i are so obsessed with
our parents like we can't like
i always say if my dad was like really
loved me he would just
let me die first like dad and i know i'm
saying this to someone whose dad said
oh you guys yeah you're not you're not
even near dead daddy's club
oh is that like really hard
i'm gonna cry thinking about it um you
know what i will
say that i think it's harder to lose a
parent um when you're older than younger
oh wow there's a part of me and i know
that sounds really maybe not [ __ ] up i
while i was devastated
i was very much in the thick of my very
selfish teenage years
yeah and i guess like not be
as devastated at that time but when i
got a like now
now it hurts me like now i can't look at
a picture of my dad or
or see anything that he's written
without having like a full-scale
meltdown
yeah because i'm older now and i feel
like i look back i'm like
i had so many questions for this man i
asked not one
you know like i wasted my time well
that's i think one of the worst parts
about when your dad dies young right
because you're not
you aren't prepared you don't you
haven't had enough life experience to
know that you're going to need to know
these things from your dad
yeah that these are things that you're
going to want to know because you're
you're in your selfish phase you're not
yeah and you're just surviving right
like this is a time when we were kind of
still new to america
so where you were just getting by like
we were just like this is life this is
tragedy you move on
it was very almost like robotic um we
didn't really have time to check in with
our
how we felt about it because we were we
didn't have a lot of money then
we were trying to sort out where my mom
was going to live so it was like and i
i was still trying to at this time i was
actively trying to still make the
olympic team for the philippines
so it was like there were too many
things happening for me
could you even imagine saying a sentence
like that
i was actively pursuing the olympia but
i didn't make it guys
so it doesn't matter and then so it was
just
we were just on survival mode i think
but but but now
let's show me one thing that might even
even a person that resembles my dad i
was i was reading a
leonard cohen um little coffee book
table and there was one picture that
leonard cohen drew that kind of
resembled my dad
and i bawled for three hours i called my
sister couldn't get over it
how she similarly yeah similarly at that
time too she was just like
we we don't have time for tears we gotta
move
and but now it's it's like just a cry
fest
esther is really gonna be the one that
needs the most help
later in life by the way i mean not that
we didn't think that
i don't know why it said that like that
would be uh wait who's gonna take care
of us when we're
old and decrepit donuts i honestly
i put in so much time with my nieces
like i put a lot of face time in with
them where i'm like i better get some
ass wipings out of this like
i talk to them every day like i really
actively i'm in there well your guy is
younger
so you're actually really set i mean
do you know that like about i only have
once once a month i just start crying
and
just for no reason then he like looks at
me he's like i'm like
one day i'm gonna look a lot older than
you and that day is
gonna come very soon that's how i feel
about bobby
he's 13 years older than me but we look
the same age and it pisses me off to no
end
no one ever ever questions our age
difference everyone's always like oh
yeah you guys look cute together
like does he not look like my old old
really really old
boyfriend no one ever brother like i'm
like taking care of my older brother or
something
never it really i'm like well what the
[ __ ] is the point of dating an older guy
if he doesn't look older than you
i know i mean what's the point of dating
a younger guy because you just starting
to look like an old
piece of [ __ ] but then you'll look
really badass like that friend
what is it the french president or
whatever who's dating like his
yeah yeah macaron yeah he'll be like
that one and then he met her when he was
only what like 14
15 and she was in her 30s
dirty what do you guys think of that i
wonder like are guys like oh that's so
cool i just i love when guys are not
creepy about like
having to have younger girls harry
styles is into older girls
we should name them harry styles nick
jonas
gerard piquet is much younger than
shakira okay someone has
really been clocking this i haven't been
for a long time
uh what's jason momoa jason momoa that
one
all the hotties all the hotties because
todd is 11 years younger than me i mean
that is
and sometimes but sometimes in style
it's cool
until you go back too far well yeah you
don't date when i started
comedy he was 14 years old like started
comedy
not like became an adult like started
this other career
i know me and dave because dave is 10
years older than me and sometimes it's
like
yeah it's like i was on stage going i
was going on stage going
um i have to date jewish guys because
i'm lactose intolerant and i can't
suck dick cheese like i was saying jokes
like that
and todd was like skateboarding
it seems like by the way isn't it kind
of weird that it's like hot
powerful men that want older women
because it's those it's like
insecure men that want like a young
little thing it's
it's true because look like boyfriends
nick jonas has always dated older women
delta goodrem
who's like at least 10 years older than
her than him i've really looked into
this by the way she's a
she's an australian pop star no there's
a thing like todd likes i think
she's married to priyanka chopra now but
well todd should we call should i call
todd and ask him why you date older
girls yeah let's do that who are we
gonna date when our old husbands die
are we gonna get back on raya when we're
60.
you guys todd will be available because
i have i'll have died
will todd take care of us as a harem
yeah we better
hello hello you're on the podcast
yes not your face so you can continue to
look disgusting if you want
um just kidding look very cute can i
talk to him
esther wants to talk to you but don't
listen to anything she said no i'll ask
him the questions unless you want to no
you can ask
she can ask todd yo why are you into
older women
i don't think it's that i'm into older
women i'm just into
maturity
maturity i'm into you know have eyes for
one person
confidence i don't think i'm into older
women i think i'm into
powerful women did everyone else get a
little slippy sloppy wet in their unders
what brb gonna go master
wait you said you don't like girls you
like women correct yeah
so do you ever worry that like about
annie's age like is that everywhere so
old and disgusting are you ever afraid
that you're underneath cataracts
like are you just afraid that one day
like caretaker she'll be her caretaker
or like she'll just show one day
what do you think happened with my
cluster no i don't worry about that
she lives a way a healthier lifestyle
than i do
and no you're you think she's super hot
are you is it like hot to you that she's
older than you
i do find it hot yeah
fetish she's fetishizing so is she a
fetish no it's not a fetish
i don't think now and what would you be
attracted to a girl younger than you or
no
i mean i could be physically attracted
to a girl younger than me but
emotionally on that emotional level and
that spiritual level
now you do know annie is emotionally
four
z7 on my way out feeling very old
okay thank you todd i'm gonna hand you
back off to on an emotional and
spiritual level he's so cute
oh he's shaved i thought you were going
to say he's shaved because
the hairs hit your special places
special places esther stop trying to see
my [ __ ]
um now what you don't like like young
girls because they
are stupid and they talk dumb right yeah
they're always like
i have a feeling todd is not attracted
to me
you're old you're old you're short we've
got to stop mistaking short for young
okay as a society we really do need to
stop
we need to get you stilt shoes so you
could be regular
i want to get you really tall let's get
us to tall shoes no you would be scared
to wear them because you'd be afraid to
fall i'm not going to wear them 90s
platform ones okay 90s platform
oh she's disgusting you just have to put
like cool words in and show you
how she likes it buzzwords okay
you guys this episode today is sponsored
by bluechu
say it with us blue
is making waves and bringing more
confidence to the bedroom by offering
chewable tablets that can help men get
stronger and longer lasting
erections bony bones
bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable form at a fraction of the cost
don't be a loner fix your boner blue
chews tablets help men achieve harder
stronger erections to combat all forms
of ed erectile dysfunction
it's an online prescription service so
no visits to the doctor office
no awkward conversations and no waiting
in line at the pharmacy and it ships
right to your door in a discreet package
the process is super simple you sign up
at bluechew.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and the best
part
it's all done online don't like
swallowing pills no problem here
bluetooth sildana fill and tadala fill
tablets are chewable
blue chews licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredients and strength for your
description prescription for your
prescription
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to
perform visit bluechew.com for more
details and important safety information
and we have
a special deal for our listeners you can
try bluetooth free when you use our
promo code
bathgirls at checkout you just pay five
dollars for shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code is bath
girls to receive your first month free
and we thank bluechu
for sponsoring this podcast
wait so you were also telling us when
you first walked in you were feeling
big and i wouldn't mind talking about
that no because you said that you had a
conversation with todd about it i feel
like todd
blew when he was eating me out he blew
into me
[Laughter]
i feel like i could float away right now
no because of my clustering okay so the
month before
my cluster headaches i hurt myself on
this row machine i was so excited that i
saw this row machine at the [ __ ]
store
and i wanted one i was like i was trying
to price it out i was like how do i it's
too big for my house how do i do it
and then whitney literally texted me it
was like rogan sent me this row machine
i'm not going to come use it come try it
out and i was like i manifested this
into
friends having rich friends jim wow
so then i todd and i were going over and
like randy would run out she's not even
there so we would just like go and use
her gym when she wasn't there
she's in her other house she's renting
the other
whatever she could own them all but um
so i was just going so hard i like hurt
my shoulder
doing it and then um so i couldn't
exercise for like i don't know like two
or three weeks before i started getting
my cluster headaches but i was like
can't wait so i was already kind of like
sedentary and just like
not eating terribly but like you know
not active
so then um i was like all right i'm my
shoulder's getting better but and then i
got my cluster headaches and my cluster
headaches are triggered by exercise so
you can't
so when i'm in the cluster-headache
cycle i can't exercise at all
but once i'm out of this convenient i
mean it's
when it's taken from you like when your
toe is broken weren't you imagining
doing
exercises when my toe was working it was
like i was so depressed it was horrible
that when i couldn't walk
i mean it was hard on one foot but um
you need all toes you need them all you
might not think it but you do
i mean if one's removed it's fine but
you can't have a sore one okay why don't
you take one i just don't want anyone
with
nine toes to get upset here they don't
have no they are stronger than me
i've broken my baby toe and what
happened i just splinted it
and asked her actually broke her big toe
but we call it her baby toe
about it wait so keep talking okay
so because of my cluster headaches i
can't exercise and then
i kind of like get into this like you
don't i'm not going to like
diet while i'm in chronic pain
you're in emergency mode you need to
treat yourself and it's not even just
treating but it's like anything that's
going to make me feel good in between
these things and there's certain things
i can't eat because they trigger the
attacks but so i couldn't have any like
sugars or sweets or anything like that
but
even though if you do if you do research
on cluster headaches it says that
like a keto diet is good for it it
wasn't like my body was
craving carbs like i like bagel like
bread
like carbs just straight carbs nothing
on the bagel just like
craving and then my headaches feel
better what
a dry bagel yeah but that's i'm telling
you it was like an animalistic
like you're a [ __ ] dry baby [ __ ]
you literally are a dry bagel
isn't it so just how dare you [ __ ] on my
i'm gonna dry bagel with hair okay get
it right
like whose hair is this ew to pretend
you don't see it and eat it
um so anyway so i've been eating like so
many carbs
and i know even though it makes me feel
better i just i'm so heavy like i never
am like a high carb eater ever in my
life i've never been
but i'm just like pasta and all this
stuff so now i'm nearing the end of my
my cluster cycle but
now i'm like enjoying shoving carbs in
my mouth it's like hard
i keep doing the diet starts tomorrow
you know no no no no not even diet but
just like regular
eating and so last night um
i did take an edible which i don't know
what this audience knows about me but
i'm we just i'm not supposed to smoke
weed or eat weed it is not supposed to
be for me
i just like to be bad so i've been like
eating edibles to go to bed
and it's just i just end up
like ordering the most amount of food
like we got pizza really late last night
give us some dinner we ordered pizza
desserts like desserts what kind
it was just it was um cheese pizza and
then we got
i got these cinnamon ball dots or
something
from where not from there's this pizza
place on third that's open till like
four in the morning which is
horrible um it's in walking distance
from
someone's house it's not mine don't rape
me and
um again again i know
guys another one would just be overkill
at this point i think i've gotten my
rapings
my ration of rapings but so um
okay so i got these cinnamon knots so
they were just like
bread balls with cinnamon on them and
you dip them in like an icing sauce
oh i oh ah are you grossed out or
i'm very emotionally turned on
dude when cinnamon things dipped in
icing sauce is like
giving us the dipping option like i get
to decide how much
they even ask i have they give you the
treat two ounces listen they give you
two ounces of the cream sauce that
you're experiencing between your legs
no of the of the icing and then you can
order
for more money like larger amounts
because people must be like this isn't
enough but it was enough
it wouldn't have been for me it would i
it was it was rough
do you like cinnabun yes i can't it's
like a banned food for me because i get
too freaky with it
my mom has like a really big addiction
to cinnabun one time we were at the
glendale galleria in the food court
and um you know sometimes they put out
well your mom is uh
well because she works out so much she
probably her metabolism's probably yeah
she
yeah she's she doesn't metabolize
anything
cinnabon food testers keep going so you
know how usually they think little
samplers out there
would and and um my mom this is what she
did
she's just on autopilot sometimes when
it comes to food and
when it comes to like free food that
someone's
order was just on the counter and it
wasn't a sampler
and she just passed by and swiped it and
just started
walking away eating the cinnamon buns
and the manager was like excuse me miss
and she just looked back like just
no [ __ ] like don't don't steal my joy
and then it wasn't until we got in the
car that i told her
mom do you know why they stopped you i
think that wasn't a sampler and then she
was just
laughing like hysterical it's a best
case scenario
it's a victimless crime really they have
to make them again yeah who gives a [ __ ]
what are you going to be out a lot of
money making dough
but it was a whole cinnabon she should
have known that wasn't the sampler size
but she she she might have known deep
down but it's like her body was like
this is what it's like when i have the
cluster headaches i need the [ __ ]
bagel one time i i think i've told you
this one time
my dad and i were at old orchard mall
and we went to the godiva shop and you
know how good i have a chocolate save
the free samples
and we were we were looking and they had
chocolate covered strawberries and we
were like
these these are the samples today that's
crazy
and there's so many and they're so big
and we just [ __ ] went in and then the
the employee came over and it's like
these are not samples they're like these
aren't real foods these
are these are shellacked for them yeah
you always 165 dollars
we just got the [ __ ] out of there oops
i like how you're you're shoving godiva
in your mouth and she's literally diving
in the ocean and
capturing oh you guys i wanted your
input on this
um i think i might be joining a spear
fishing competition
will you guys go to arkansas with me
i've never been yes can we have the
can we eat the fish yeah so there's
there's striper
i'm no longer vegan there's striper and
carp
i don't know if you're into those but
they're delicious uh george's
esther's vegan between the hours of
midnight and
7 a.m i think you say vegan between the
legs
there is nothing fishy there icing just
straight up
i was gonna say she's she's pescatarian
down there because
it's a fish fillet um i okay so
i have a memory of my parents my dad and
i do this too like we go to the mall and
we
that's like our favorite pastime we mall
walk and then we just do mostly laps in
the food court
and he has a guy at the cheesesteak
place that hates him
like knows him and he's he's convinced
that there's a conspiracy against
somebody always gives him the small one
which i'm like just give my dad the big
one and maybe he won't come back for a
second one
but we always like take pictures with
all of our um toothpicks at the end
like that's a sad thing maybe we won't
have again oh no
do you guys come back are you guys um
complainers if you
if you're not satisfied with your food
do you tell the manager or the server or
do you just let it be in
i used to be but now i'm not as much but
she wants to get married still she
doesn't want to be alone
i my dad raised me to be vocal about
like like assert your needs and
sometimes though i go back on that and i
just like take what i've
been given and it doesn't feel good my
stepdad is very much like you in that
way where it's like
no if you you're paying for this if you
if it's not up to
what you thought then you should let
someone know but i'm so anti that
and i'm like look everyone's just doing
their best if it's not good use it as a
as reference and never come back to this
restaurant but that's almost hurting the
restaurant right so like
as for me like what do you if you were
the restaurant wouldn't you want to know
so that you have the customer come back
i think it doesn't matter
like if it's a real issue i just have a
feeling that you
more often don't like what you get than
when you do that
no well i do reorder the same thing over
and over again because i do you're
scared
of but i will tell you this one time i
was at veggies
it's so cute i was at veggie girl with
carlos and
we got our food and there was a bug in
my food and i freaked out
and i'm like oh my god like i'm so
nervous and like we gave back they
they you know they gave us new food i
think they refunded us and then when we
left the restaurant
i noticed that the bugs were coming from
my hair
and it was my problem that's not an okay
stupid we have to cut that story i can't
allow them
esther why were bugs in your hair i
don't really
did you just like brush up against like
a tree before you
i don't know there was just but then
there was like three more of them that
came out of my hair
and this is when we found that asteroid
crabs top crabs
there's a place on third street again i
do not live there
but um there's a place on third street
that is called ferry
something and it's just a head lice tour
i don't understand
it just is a head lice store what do
they sell i have no clue i've never gone
into i don't think it's
it survives the pandemic it's called
fairy something
i'm going to say something controversial
lice having lice is so
fun why i had crabs and i loved it
right i had crabs in college i it was
the funniest time it's when i decided to
be a comedian
why because it was i had joy in it
rather than upset like
telling people i had crabs was so funny
and it was like i mean it was gross but
it was like
yeah and i flicked them on my friend was
in town who was an actual prostitute on
craigslist
her and her boyfriend would like pee on
each other for money and i
and she came to my house and i was so
pissed i had crabs and she didn't
that i flicked them on her i was like
come here [ __ ] and i was like flicking
my face
in the philippines we call them well we
call like ticks karapata
but they're like the red ones that kind
of you know the the one
before they get like gray and juicy have
you seen dog ticks
todd just took one off randy yesterday
it was really hot he did a really good
job he squeezed it
yeah pulled very slight pressure and got
the whole thing out of still alive i
could tick
because wait wait how did he get a tick
because dogs yeah if you walk your dog
go to the park
if you've ever like done anything to
like exercise your dog i've never seen a
tick on my dog
you have to look you have to like care
about your dog i look at her i'm always
examining her little body
they're not always on the vagina um
well um we have ticks in la that's how
you get lyme disease
please lord do not give esther lyme
disease please lord i will not make it
through
i will not survive this if esther gets
lyme disease
i will not be able to live another day
the reason lice having lice is really
fun
is because you have your whole family
now doting on you
and brushing your hair with a light it's
not good to see your little teddy bear
in the bag yeah and then have you ever
done this to like a really fat lice go
pop
pop their little body oh it's the best
it's like
getting a black head out that's been
there for three months
like a d-pal she anything you didn't
have in life she had so hard
oh god tell me i have lice it's the
greatest day let me celebrate my mom
says this to me
so randomly she'll call me be like you
know what i really wish i had lice right
now
because the feeling the itch someone
like going through your hair popping a
little tiny little comb
that does sound nice and it does give me
memories of like when you at school you
got checked for lice and they put their
plastic gloves on
and they're like touching your head and
i'm just like they're just spreading you
feel special
yeah yep can we do like a cosplay where
like one day we all put those gloves on
and play with each other's hair and we
actually find lice on you
my brother used to get fleas in his head
because our our childhood dog would like
sleep on top of his head
and gave him head fleas but we were
swimmers i feel like the chlorine should
have killed those
let me tell you i was a swimmer and i
had a whole lot of life we were dirty
because honestly like that you you know
like the trash family in the
neighborhood
you know that was you i but i didn't
realize until i was older because the
school i went to
this school uh i went to green street
friends was a quaker school it was in
germantown
and germantown's like a pretty cool area
of philadelphia
and there was this one like really dirty
white family that lived it was
they were like kind of on our campus it
was just like a really weird like their
house was like it was like our
playground and then their house was
right there
and it was like there was a trash pile
in the back like they had just like
dirty old things everywhere and the kids
would just emerge
sometimes we're so scared of them they
were like hills of eyes kids like ah we
would just run away from them
they were so scary um but i realized in
my neighborhood we were the trash family
like we didn't really have like trash on
our lawn but like we
that's so fun though we were the we were
the family
to be just the the worst types of people
and not know it i love it now like i
look back and i and i do like as much as
i
like have gone through my issues with my
parents stuff i'm like i really was
raised very free
i would not be this type of psycho that
seems to work sometimes may i say having
a house near a high school is really fun
oh i'm
so jealous of that i would pass back
elementary school that's a little risky
yeah that's not fun a high school
because i used to live right by
marshall high school in pasadena and
when i would get off my bus my 401 on
allen
i would walk past the baseball team um
when they were
either scrimmaging or having practice
and it was
how i landed like a hot boy i would just
make sure
like five minutes before i'd get off the
bus i'd have my little compact and i'd
make sure my hair was on point
and i'd make sure that you know my yeah
and it was just a strut
every day a stretch yes the strut okay
tell me this when you had a crush on a
boy
how did you handle it in middle school
or in high school because
high school and middle school are the
same thing for you
you tell me because i don't really have
it i don't feel like i have a good
answer oh i had moves
i would find i would know their
um schedule like i would have seen you
know i would
stock the halls to know where they're
gonna be i would make sure i walked by
and i would just
tell everyone they knew that i had a
crush on them because i was it was just
this like i just
knew you told them you would have a
crush on them i told people around and
then i would just be available now were
you also a student at the school at the
time
[Laughter]
i was the janitor guys cove it's been
hard i had to get a new job the hot
janitor is a crush on me the strut
involves making sure that your pager is
on the right side so they can they see
your green motorola pager so they know
you're reachable
yes you know yeah yeah no for real like
you have you were very like
it just giving that vibe that it's like
you can come get it
and it always worked yeah i think i by
the time that was senior year for me i
had a little bit more confidence then
and so i did it i dated sergio
sergio was a baseball player he was also
a
hot name he eventually crawled through
my window one time and
boxed my face because i didn't call him
back what boxed her face punched it
boxed it you punched my head yeah
did he really yeah because his school
was right next to my house like that's
in her face i thought that was like he
thought you were ugly so he put a box
over your head and [ __ ] yeah
i've had that yeah so that's the
downside of it is people love doing
doggy with
us
when guys spin you esther do they go
so it turns out bobby says he's a
spinner oh my god he is a spinner
yeah he's compact enough to be a spinner
that's why you never have to be
threatened by esther two spinners never
work
[Laughter]
you guys magic spoon i
think i ate four bowls this week for
dinner
separate nights not one night are you
guys not addicted to it i am which one's
your favorite
fruity of course it's fruity i'm a
classic frosted
kind of guy you guys are crazy no you're
all crazy
fruity when there's an option for peanut
butter you take it lucky for you guys it
comes in a variety pack so you can have
all four and chews and let us know which
one of your out of those four is your
favorite
it's zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams
of protein
and only four grams of net carbs in each
serving it's cereal it tastes like your
favorite cereal that you had growing up
but it's actually good for you it
doesn't have rotten bad things in it
and only 140 calories a serving it's
keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
and gmo free and the best part is they
have all of
the games that you enjoyed as a kid on
the back of the boxes i did a mad libs
the other day
and you guys can go to magicspoon.com
bathgirls to grab a variety pack and try
it today and be sure to use our promo
code
bathgirls at checkout to save five
dollars off your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund you no questions asked so
literally if you
trust one of us you should order it and
try it and if you don't like it you can
get your money back and if
and if anyone was gonna send it back to
get that money back it would be esther's
she does like it remember get your next
delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com bathgirls and use the
code bathgirls to save five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
it's like pawns you need a slammer and
uh
i was so good at pogba thank you for
referencing paul
you having a religious experience
i love you my pogs wherever you are did
you guys collect the best slammers
yes [ __ ] but i really only there was
only like really
one year that i was in were probably
around for one year yeah they came
and went pretty quick yeah they did but
the the perfect slammer was not too
heavy and not too light people thought
that the heavier their slammer was the
more they could flip and it wasn't that
it would really involve technique we
should have a pog contest
like now that i'm thinking like what did
we do we flipped we flipped them but you
have to hit it at an
angle and at the right weight for it to
flip the whole
because you never just wanted one or two
pogs you wanted the whole deck to flip
and that's when you're a champion i'm
very good at pugs
you know what it was all her experience
popping lice i got a really good
great motor fine motorcycle should we
call my mom and see if she knows where
my pogs are yes
please oh my god i hope she threw them
out i want to see this
mom yeah where are my pogs
my pogs do you still have my pogs
what the hell are pugs explain to your
mama pogs are because
they're not easy to do you remember my
pogs there were those little circles
like kind of like cardboard with
pictures on them and they came in little
cases and they had slammers there were
toys i had lots
yeah okay so where are they oh i don't
know
[Laughter]
if your dad pulls his finger his middle
finger out of his pocket i don't know
what he has
i got him right here but seriously
mom is there any chance the pogs are in
the crawl space
oh i don't have a clue [ __ ]
space we'll show you something yeah get
in there i'll shut the door real quick
behind you all right well
thanks okay sorry bye miss you
bye um maybe your dad is my hero
we have the exact same attack on you
maybe that's why i like
you're like my daddy that is so funny
my dad someone would say that exact same
thing they're very similar
old dads once my dad um
my mom used to make stained glass and
she made this beautiful stained glass
for my dad's
uh my dad was the treasurer of the
university of pennsylvania
no big d so why the [ __ ] were you guys
raised like trash
it's who you are inside it makes no
sense
well my dad my dad was just really smart
and like mensa
and ended up like working his way up but
he my mom was
was brought up in like a really nice
like upper middle class place in upstate
new york
and my dad popped out of a tuna again
like i like i swear to god i'm halfway
trash
half tuna and he but he's just so
smart he's like undeniably smart he just
got he just rose his way up
but anyway so he when he retired
he was having all these like emotions
about it and stuff so he had to take
this he had this beautiful like window
and he had the stained glass in the
window at his office so he took it home
and um you know i'm sure in his head
this was like a representation of his
like
you know aging and life process and
everything
so it's sitting there and me and my
brother just get in a fight like i'm
like [ __ ] max i like throw a brush at
him and he ducks
and it just cracks one of the panels now
it's not hard to fix
but when this is like you're like i just
retired i'm all like
it's a very big deal so my dad is just
like
livid max and i were crying we're
probably 19. we're weeping we're like
maybe we're 16 or something cause he
retired early but we were like we were
crying like small children we were so
scared our dad was so mad at us
and he was like i would tell you to go
play in traffic but you'd probably
survive and then i have to take care of
you for the rest of your [ __ ] lives
it was just so funny like i'll be spoon
feeding you like he was just
he's so like even in his like fit of
rage
and like his whole life in front of his
eyes he still has such
good jokes he's just good isn't it crazy
how
like we would see the like the fear that
would overcome my body
because i truly believe like my parents
or my mom wanted to kill me yeah like
that's that's a real thing right like i
know that feeling right like my sister's
about to what my ass
uh-huh oh it's gotta run it's like
imminent
imminent danger we were like oh this is
how and then your life flashes before
your eyes i'm like i want to live
more well mine was like
sicker because mine was just like i want
them to love me like it wasn't like i
think they're going to kill me it was
like
are they not going to like me
that's so sad do you not like me as a
person
i'm way saturday i'm still on their dick
but should we banana break
yeah we should yeah and i do want to
finish because i do have to tell you
guys more of eating story because
some funny [ __ ] went down the other day
we should make um our own line of pogs
yes
as collectibles by the way if your mom
knew what pogs were that would be
so upset she did after a quick
explanation but yeah
i was sad that she didn't know right
away what would you do if she had thrown
them out
i think there's a chance she doesn't
have to feel like i'm the only banana
connoisseur here
you are no give me banana oh by the way
i vomited up some of the grossest foods
ever
after that [ __ ] last episode i have a
video of me throwing up if you want to
add it in i felt energized
oh my god oh my god wait george can you
play a video
on the screen yeah it is my
favorite video and it is exactly the
thing that kaleidoscope is like chris
medina
singing i don't know lyla and i had a
sidebar that we have to fill you in on
hold on start from the very beginning
please know that this is this is the the
imminent fear that you talked about
[Laughter]
i was the bigger like my brother once
threw uh batteries at me
i've never seen anyone run for their
lives the only room that had a lock was
this one bathroom in our house
and the my brothers would jet to it and
lock themselves in because
i would [ __ ] them up and i did not care
about their balls
my brother didn't go to school one day
because i kicked him in the ball
you guys never wait did we talk about
this last time we you guys were never
you never did burn books right
no have you i i never did them i had
them
done to me i found a burn book and
flipped through it and was like
oh i was really this is how sad and
desperate i was when i first moved
to the u.s i really wanted to see if
people even knew who i
am who or who i was in school um
and i started a burn book to see even i
would have been happy if they had put me
under any of the even the bad categories
of like
you know what i mean ugliest knows or
wait well can you just
just explain what a burn book is to you
because well burn book for me
is it's not like the typical mean girls
one in mean girls they just talk
you know you write your feelings about
somebody in school a burn book for me
would be like
you know like for instance like shortest
legs or worst kisser
or biggest [ __ ] and they would have
categories and you would write a name on
there and then if you agreed with one
you would just put the points
you would just add points to each name
and why would you find the book
um it would be passed around school like
each person
biggest [ __ ] is actually like low-key
such a big compliment
in retrospect if you think about it
because that probably meant they just
thought you were hot
well i wanted to have it could have been
any category i just wanted to see my
name
and i didn't so zero you started it you
should put your name in it
well no i wanted to see if others were
thinking about me if i was even on
anyone's radar
but i wonder if you had like planted
something about yourself in
it if people would have piled on why do
you probably why do you think you
weren't in it
because i was new to america and i was
just really like a studious athlete
this is before that that's something
like this oh she works and then after
that burn book i was like no one knows
who i am i better
show him who i am and i started sucking
a whole lot a day
sucked her away right into that burner
then by senior year i was on
every page of every person the only
thing burning her pee was
i um wait that's sorry wait that's a
weird position to be in where you're the
hot
new i wasn't hot you weren't hot no no
no i had um
really really short hair a whole lot of
gums and retainers over those gums
and um how did you get rid of all
because i used to not have a gu
i got my gums cut out at 15 because i
had braces too young when i was 10
and so my gums got really really swollen
and so when i came to america
the dentist was like oh like you we
gotta cut some of your gums out
really and so they they did well i don't
know what they did
but um eventually i had teeth again ever
since i had invisalign
when i smile i have too much gum now and
i'm like
when did you get invisalign like three
years ago maybe they're just maybe
that's swollen
maybe they're just swollen they're not
even let me see you well maybe you like
your teeth and you smile more
because that's what happens when you
when your teeth get pushed back together
because i had gaps right
no so my teeth used to be much more
forward
so like the gums were back and the teeth
were forward and now
can we get a before picture of your
teeth no no no can i show you guys
uh um i'd like to show you guys a
picture of
of um my gums i would like to see you in
high school
wouldn't it be funny if she just showed
us a picture of her vagina
i might come she's like check out my
gums that's like what you guys
always said you want to see a picture of
my dog to people and then i would show
them just a picture of her
that was my vagina who's vagina my dogs
oh god don't say pictures have you guys
do you guys know like
you can't have you ever seen those teeth
in places where they don't belong
no in other parts of the body the
vaginal teeth
like yeah they're called like teratomas
yeah they're just made out of like
random i'm very territorial about my
territory like
it's almost like a mini version of
yourself stuck in another part of your
body it can be made of teeth
hair is that what it is yeah it can look
like a little baby human
that's like a little hemorrhoid esters
where do you see those
sometimes everyone has them they're
tumors and random parts of your body
wait before we move on i'd like to if
your nipples are sensitive it means
there's teeth in them
carry on without me guys you guys okay
so my burn book story
no school no george those are
territories ew
esther you have to eat that next episode
ew look at the toes
guys that's why i blur my feet that's
not real i have teeth toes
why is that happening i ha i'm not good
i'm not good making esther not good once
an episode is a
demand i have it's a demand i'm not good
that's really worse than you could think
it's getting worse i'm not good
we're really getting worse
i'm not good i'd be weird do you have to
brush your toe teeth
to go in all right shut the [ __ ] up now
you gotta floss in between your toe
teeth
she's shut her up she's bad nobody can
many have tried nobody can i would have
you think sticking a dick in my mouth
shuts me up oh
boy or do you have something to learn
boy is her mouth tired
boy honestly that's why my voice is so
deep because i've never stopped talking
i would give anything to have teeth in
my [ __ ]
anything so um i could
um keep him in there until his dick gets
soft
she's a guy she's anxious attached
she's very scared of abandonment she
needs to grip her teeth into your dick
oh
god i okay so the burn book i get the
burn book okay i'm like
you know the hundredth person to get it
so it's all filled in and stuff
i don't write anything in it because
even though i'm like i am
like a born bully i kicked my twin
brother out of the womb legit
kicked him out i came up feet first he
was head first first
um born bully i just that quakerism got
in me i just like could not
bring myself to write things like it's
too mean and so i but i was
assuming like my friends probably didn't
i get to my name
and just [ __ ] in my best friend's
handwriting
oh i was so mad wait is this the best
friend
that was my friend it's not the one that
stole my mom my friend mickey from
middle school
because there's been an ongoing
conspiracy
regarding um a mole and
yeah and so there is tell us the back
story
so here's i think you could have cropped
it you didn't need to
that is a pretty hot picture when is
that picture from before my period
obviously
it was probably the day before i popped
blood
look at those chi-chi's wow you guys i
am really impressed with myself in this
that's a good who wouldn't want to steal
a mole from this girl okay
so backstory so i have this i had this
friend
who friended me in high school who i've
mentioned her name's
on this podcast is becky and she
uh we had some falling outs i mean and
this is like she told the cops i was
lying that my teacher expect like these
are bad these are like some serious
serious issues we had they weren't just
regular high school issues wait is this
the same
um girl who stole your boyfriend right
yeah she stole my boyfriends
and she also told the cops i was lying
when i took my teacher to court
and yeah she told she literally i went
into the
and they said oh you're she said that
you are a pathological liar
that's crazy isn't that just so [ __ ]
up
but anyway i then did landmark and
decided to be friends with her again
when i was 19. i was like
wow it must have been my fault she's a
[ __ ] um
so then i befriended her again and then
we had another falling out
where she was i went to the restaurant
she worked out with my mom
and um she was like serving us and she
got mad at me for talking to the table
next to us where it's like
they were talking to us it was like not
even like a bed she came and she's like
andy this is fine dining which by the
way wasn't
she like this and pushed me physically
pushed me and i was just like
okay well you're not allowed to chit
chat um
when it's a fine dining place we were
like in a booth i'm like why would a
fine dining place have a but whatever it
doesn't matter it's like who i'm sure i
was annoying
i'm sure i just the story i do i take
the other side it's just like
why would you put you pushed me [ __ ]
but i also was looking at her like
are you like don't you feel still feel
bad that you said i was a liar to the
cops
but uh you're pushing now you're
physically pushing me but anyway so that
i stopped being friends with her but
i she's very hard to stalk i love doing
a nice stalking
on the internet and she's not this is
what we have in common
she's not she's down she's not available
so i've searched for our search for her
search for her
she finally she's doing very well for
herself which as
i'm having how so she um
she got married to this chef and she
owns a restaurant her parents were kind
of in the restaurant industry so it's
like her thing
and she has a really nice restaurant um
i before when we became friends again
in the landmark era we went to the same
hairdresser
okay and when i went to the when i went
to my hairdresser i said i think it was
her hairdresser first i will give her
that
but when i saw my hairdresser she said
that that becky had asked to look like
me
no yes no she became a blonde she had
brown hair no
she became a blonde and she got the side
bangs i had at that time
she had asked to look like me okay so
this is important information to know
for what i'm about to accuse her of
we were best 14 to whatever restaurants
like we were around each other a lot
that is by the way i'm already getting
visions like this is something i would
do
like have a best friend and then try to
become them yeah you single white female
yeah
i've had a few of those esther's never
never had them you're not someone i'd
become
but you're someone more like i just like
obsessed with
i'm not like i don't want to be you
no you want to be in me
um we know we know esther what you want
to get up there she wants to get into
that uterine lining
see if there's any teeth getting those
teeth [ __ ] teeth um uh so okay so
could never really find her finally
found her on the stuff so when i google
her i have to google her name
i found her husband's last name so i had
to google her
um because she there was like a
photographer that had her name i mean i
i dug
it was hard okay i found her
and was google imaging her and there's
like three pictures
right all of a sudden
she has a mole but it's black okay
it's not mole colored it's a black mole
wait that's what she looks like yeah
zoom do you see the mole it's black and
it's flat
like it's not actually there she kind of
looks like you i know
look she does look like a brunette
version of you
but do you see how it looks
i think she stole my mole i think and
i'm gonna go as far as to say i think
she's not online because she did me
[ __ ] dirty and i know that's
narcissistic
but i think why like what shady [ __ ]
are you hiding that you're not online at
all wait i have a question annie
yeah so you're saying this is what
you're saying she never had a mole in
her cheeks remember listen i would think
i would remember if my best friend and i
had the same mole this is a very
distinct moment i've had my entire life
right
you're right because bobby and i have
the same broken finger and middle
fingernail and that's something that we
bonded over
so yes it's something that you cannot
miss yeah and somebody but i will say
that
sun exposure right it could be that sun
exposure
caused this current mole that she has on
her it looks black like
the same color as her eyebrow pencil
like it looks colored into me
or what if she had a pimple and then she
just turned it into a more there's other
pictures no
come on i don't do that in high school i
know obviously copied i
there's no there's just not a
coincidence here
that that is not her copy but isn't it
crazy that i've not seen this girl
a single white but i know she thinks
about i know
i know i'm behind some of you she
bridget funded you
oh my god i'm just imagining putting a
[ __ ] teal spike in her arm so you
guys are still mad at her
um some i go back and forth because i'm
like how could i be mad at a 16 year old
still
right as a grown up i could do that but
i get very
like like i obviously i am i'm like
happy for her she definitely like is
like
living her best life like this is like
her version probably of doing comedy
is that she owns this restaurant she's
very like this is her version of her
blood bath yeah well she's very like
she was one of those girls that would
like drop a pencil and like pick it up
with her like
let knees straight and like was always
like kind of like uh like
she was just put on and try to get
attention and very like
she wanted the boys to want her and she
wanted the boys to want well they did
yeah want her more than me which was
very difficult it was very upsetting
do we forgive in in bloodbath do we
forgive
or do we hold grudges i really try to
forget for myself
like i do think when you're angry and
you're mad at people still it does
sometimes help you
motivate you but for me what i don't
know sorry i keep going
what do you think what do you think
esther do we forgive or do we hold a
grudge against our high school bullying
i
i don't know like i can't remember i
don't know that ever said anything mean
to me
i can't figure it out i don't know who i
hold a grudge against but i want to
i want to hold a grudge you honestly
liking being
abused has probably kept you from having
a lot of enemies
yeah i don't take things personally
because you let you know that it's like
a
yeah i don't i'm trying to think of a
grudge because i know they've been there
you know my high school x is a whole
thing
i'm looking at your face when you a
little bit have my same mole
i'm like does everyone have this mall
and i've just never noticed i have one
in that
cheek no you do have one don't you i
have a lot of moles let's have annie
moldy we'll all come in with one
but i'm like like i know but okay you
guys in the comments section please let
us
know what you think about this mole
conspiracy if you think someone stole
annie's mole
if a mole has been stolen we should
maybe dine in at her restaurant and
confront her and do you also vote for
hold grudges
or give forgiveness we i i need
to be told which one to choose i'm a
forgiver i gotta forget i just can't
like
it's because when i do get like
triggered i i'll i'll have this visceral
reaction to this girl and i'm like
how 21 years later
am i still a whole human can drink
alcohol in the time
that i like one of my whole boyfriends
was created
in this time but it's such an
impressionable time where things really
feel um you feel a lot like tiny
small things really make you feel a lot
at that age like for instance like i
recently forgave the guy
not recently i've forgiven him for a
long time who told the whole school that
like i
you know that i was a face queen right
and um
maybe we should give him a call next
week but he basically was the reason why
i was called a [ __ ] throughout
high school and um i just um
we should call him next let's call can
we call the guy my friend that i gave a
[ __ ] to in high school that was like
the worst [ __ ] i've ever given we
will love to rate this [ __ ]
oh we should call our exes to raid our
[ __ ] is that a new segment
esther's like i've but i've never i
i will we can call my exes though would
love to yeah
i i will say i love a good grudge
isn't that good there's nothing more
motivating than a good grudge i'm like
craving a grudge
as long as are you jealous that i have a
black haired version of me
yeah i'm gonna graduate i'm gonna go
mate with her
please i wish you could find her it's
like she's private on fire i'm gonna
inseminate her
i i dug though i dug and i found it you
know what really triggered me though and
this is like
it was like an it was a newspaper
article
about like how people are doing and
people in the city are doing in covid
or maybe their coveted style or
something and up
pops a picture of her like
eight months pregnant and i'm like
so jealous is that something that gets
you it never
used to but it's like it kind of pisses
me off i'm like okay
you literally like told the cut you
threw me under the bus you told the cops
i was a liar like that's such a crazy
thing to do to someone
i had to come into the school the next
day and the only way you got kicked out
of my high school was if you
threw a punch at someone so i like had
my fist i walked into her spanish class
and i like started pounding the table in
front of her
she hated the word [ __ ] and i was like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] like i was just
like
i was like she was i have nothing to say
to you and i was like you [ __ ]
i'm a liar [ __ ] like i just couldn't
believe i was like
what are you crazy and um the teachers
had to like pull me back and then i got
y'all i remember being like how the [ __ ]
are you
in this [ __ ] first of all you let a
teacher jizz on me [ __ ] scumbags
and then you [ __ ] all are somehow not
on my side coming out with this
and then now you're like acting like
this is a victim of me
this [ __ ] [ __ ] just told the cops
i'm a pathological
a pathological liar i will say i wonder
because
i'm still very pissed we do keep
referencing this is a grudge this is a
forever grudge i think we do keep
referencing
the big story and i do think maybe if
you're comfortable
soon oh my gosh should we have a
countdown to my molested story
i do think that like because you keep
referencing it and i know if i was
listening i'd want to know it
i i could be bottomless
so i do think maybe if you maybe i can
tell the whole story you'll tell the
whole story
but i go through waves of being like not
now please
please don't tell us now for the love of
god
shut your [ __ ] i'm gonna bring visual
aids i'm gonna bring some elmer's glue
oh we have a lot look behind you it's a
glue wall oh my god
i'm gonna squirt him go and then he went
like this
esther can i use your knee pit
will you lend me a knee pit we can do an
interpretive dance
of it wait you know what i did that i've
had a boy um [ __ ] my knee pit
oh what nobody is really surprised it
doesn't feel good i'm not the way i try
it
we're gonna be on wiki feet just from
your feet no we're not because the
camera's not pointing that way
i'll i don't care my feet are nobody
wants these
they do esther you guys thank you for
listening to this
chaotic wild hang
this is a hang on this is a this is a
hang um
you guys any uh announcements from
anyone
i just feel i i feel very i'm grateful
for you guys i would like to see some
photos of you guys stealing my mole tag
us
bloodbath girls will be posted and if
you guys at one point in your
life had really really big gums please
send your picture
to me that would make me feel so much
better no me
sure okay true yeah i had um i
i have amazingly white perfect mouth now
but
um i did have bumpy gums in high school
they they
pounded it out i have a clothing line
sleepoverbyester.com there's some of
these still left maybe
sleepoverbaster.com check it out and i'm
coming to arizona
april 29th at 8 o'clock at stand up live
you can get tickets on their website
she's there to watch the show
i will be there in the audience um i'll
see you guys in phoenix she'll be your
waitress
we'll see you guys next week bye guys
[Music]
you